Ben is in Indianapolis - welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hey thanks Dave
I was calling to get some tithing
guidance from you okay I was raised in a
Christian tithing paying home and
working my way back to that my wife was
not as she had a good job she made over
$100,000 and she's quit stay at home to
raise her two-year-old I have a good
income I've been blessed i fluctuate
between about 175 to 200 and trying to
bring up subject to potentially pain she
sees it as a an extra seventeen to
twenty thousand dollar a year tax of
trying to get out of that mindset just
wanted to see what I got I assume she's
not a Christian she she is I mean she's
coming around to it she's coming around
coming around to what site yeah yeah she
you know in the last five years you know
we're in our mid 30s as she didn't have
any any religion so we met and then I've
slowly been myself coming back to it and
feel strong about it she supports me in
that are you attending church yes yeah I
am she comes with me on occasion okay
all right this is not a financial
discussion this is a spiritual
discussion okay here because what she is
saying is perfectly logical from her
perspective because her perspective is
not one where God is the lord of her
life at this stage and that's not
calling her names or calling her out in
any way but if someone is not a person
of faith to ask them to tithe it is a
tax it does feel like that and so this
has to do with the level of faith that
she has and the maturity of that faith
in other words God is not in charge of
her life right now right as we're back
at giving milk versus me I'd deal well
we're we're back to asking someone who's
not a Christian to tithe
I think she's approaching her faith
she's beginning to feel it out she's
wondering about it but she has not
embraced
completely yet and when she does that
then tithing will have to come from a
different discussion because of tithe
for you and I we understand God owns at
all and he's asking us to give a tenth
of what he already owns it is in charge
of our life you and me but if he's not
in charge of somebody's life then it's
weird to them to tithe does that make
sense well it does and so I would I
would not argue with her about tithing
you know I might come to some compromise
and just say as a part of my faith this
is very important to me and so I want to
do at least this level because tithing
as you know is not a Salvation issue
here it doesn't it doesn't get you saved
and doesn't make God like you more it's
just his instruction to us as believers
to be givers and the tie the tithe is
the baseline the plumb line for that
it's the starting point but God's not
mad at her over this or you if you don't
give a full tithe and so I would be a
lot more concern with you know attending
a church where faith is attractive for
her and and her to be there in a
situation where she can meet God in a
really deep way and then the tithe will
be to come the the result the byproduct
of that I've not met anybody who I've
never met a lady whose husband said
we're going to start tithing because I
demand it and they and they say oh okay
I love God now that doesn't work you
know won't work at all no oh no had a
good income and now she's not yeah she's
raising her child and this is this lady
this lady you know your wife's a bright
lady I mean she makes you make big money
and so she's going to intellectually
approach her faith as well and she's
going to want to argue through some of
the tough questions regarding faith and
it's going to be a great journey for you
all as she approaches it but and then I
so I would put the tithe on the back
burner as a discussion instead of it
being a barrier to her to her sticking
her toe in the water about faith I would
remove that barrier ya know your that's
a great point
that you're right there doesn't need to
be any barriers between her and God at
this point yes that's the wall well I
like the sliding scale approach as well
yeah and that's gonna come in a net
because again I think the goal is five
years from now she has a deep and
abiding thriving faith that is
intellectually and spiritually based
that would be appealing to someone like
her that has comes to in a you know in a
proper way and then the net result of
that is the two of you walking together
naturally decide to tithe now that's
exactly it
so that's well that's how I go out and I
would go at it from the bottom up so to
speak instead of the top down and it's a
good discussion you know the tie there's
a lot of times a spiritual discussion it
was with me because I didn't grow up in
church and so when the preacher said he
wanted tenth of my income I went right
you gotta be kidding me that's my first
reaction it's kind of like your wife
really
and so but then when I actually accepted
the Lord and said okay you're in charge
now and then I say okay what's the
handbook say oh that's what it says okay
we do it they have access it was a
natural reaction for me even as
rebellious and tough and grouchy as I am
sometimes so anyway but that's how I
approached it too it was tied into my
faith this is the Dave Ramsey show
you